construct a regular hexagon inscribed
inside the circle so I'm going to do
first I'm going to draw a diameter of
the circle actually I'm going to go
beyond the diameter of the circle I'm
just going to draw a line that goes
through the center of the circle and
just keeps on going and I'm going to
make it flat so it goes directly through
so this one right over here goes
directly through the center and now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to
construct a circle that's the exact same
dimensions of this circle that's already
been drawn so let me put this one right
over here let me make it the same
dimensions and now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to move it over so that
this new circle intersects the center of
the old circle and these circles are the
same size so notice this Center
intersects the old circle and the new
circle itself intersects the center of
the old circle now the reason why this
is interesting we already know that this
distance the distance between these two
centers this is equal to a radius we
also know we also know me at a
straightedge we also know that this
distance right over here is equal to a
radius it's equal to the radius of our
new circle right over here we also know
that this distance right over here is
equal to a radius of our old circle and
that they both have the same radius so
this is a radius between these two
points between these two points in
radius and then in between these two
points is a radius so now I have
constructed an equilateral triangle and
essentially I have to just do this six
times and then I'm going to have a
hexagon inscribed inside the circle let
me do it again so go from here to here
this is a radius of my new circle which
is the same as the radius of the old
circle and I could go from here to here
that's the radius of my old circle so I
have another equilateral triangle radius
radius radius another equilateral
triangle I just kind of do this I have
to do this four more times so let me go
to my original let's see let me make
sure I can well it's actually going to
be hard for me to let me just add
another circle here
to do it on the other side so if I put
it the center of it right I want to move
it a little bit right over I want to
make it the same size so that's close
enough and let's see that looks pretty
pretty close that's the same size and
let me move it over over here now I want
this Center to be on the circle right
like that and now I'm ready to draw some
more equilateral triangles so a day and
really I don't have to even draw the
inside of it now I see my my six
vertices for my hexagon here here here
here here here and I think you're
satisfied now that it you could break
this up into six equal lateral triangles
so let's do that so this would be the
base of one of those equilateral
triangles and actually let me move these
let me move this one out of the way I
can move this one right over here
because I really just care about the
hexagon itself and I can move this right
over here but we know that these are all
the lengths of the radius anyway
actually I'm not even having to change
the length there then I have to just
connect one more right down here so let
me add another straight edge connect
those two points and I would have done
it I would have constructed my I've
constructed my regular hexagon inscribed
in the circle